oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
um
hello
[Music]
oh
so
thank you more just
this
right
[Music]
uh
[Music]
right
well
act surely is our common purpose
your majesty i now invite you to address
the scottish parliament
presiding officer
first minister
members of the scottish parliament
it is a pleasure to be invited to
address you on this special occasion
i would like to begin by thanking you
for presiding officer for your kind
words of welcome
i would also like to congratulate you
and the scottish parliament as a whole
for being able to mark the new session
of parliament in this safe and welcoming
manner during what has been a very
trying period
presiding officer you carry the weighty
responsibility
of being a strong advocate for the
parliament
and i know you will strive to use your
judgment
to lead this parliament by demonstrating
fairness
respect
and impartiality
members of the scottish parliament
as we all step out from adverse and
uncertain times
occasions such as this
today provide an opportunity for hope
and optimism
marking this new session does indeed
bring a sense of beginning and renewal
the scottish parliament has been at the
heart of scotland's response to the
pandemic
with people across this country
looking to you for leadership and
stewardship
and i hope you will remain at the
forefront as we move towards a phase of
recovery
while some of you will have differences
of opinion
i trust you will continue to work
together
your service here is carried out in the
presence of the mace
and i encourage you to draw inspiration
from the founding principles of wisdom
justice
compassion and integrity
these words are a reminder of your
responsibilities to the people of
scotland
and in the years ahead i hope you can
reaffirm their important to everything
you do
as a member of this parliament
today is also a day when we can
celebrate those who have made an
extraordinary contribution to the lives
of other people in scotland
locally or nationally
during the covid19 pandemic
i have spoken before
of my deep and abiding affection for
this wonderful country and of the many
happy memories prince philip and i
always held of our time here
it is often said that it is the people
that make a place
and there are few places where this is
truer than in scotland
as we have seen in recent times
we all know of the difficult
circumstances that many people have
encountered during the last 18 months
however alongside this they've become
countless examples of resilience and
goodwill
following my grandson's time as lord
high commissioner prince william has
told me many heartening stories that he
heard
firsthand of people and communities
across scotland uniting to protect and
care for those who are isolated or
vulnerable
it is only fitting that we use this
occasion to acknowledge and thank these
remarkable people
who have made such a positive difference
to so many
members of the scottish parliament
as i said earlier
the beginning of a new session is the
time for renewal and fresh thinking
providing an opportunity to look to the
future
and our future generations
next month
i will be attending cop 26 events in
glasgow
the eyes of the world will be on the
united kingdom and scotland in
particular
as leaders come together to address the
challenges of climate change
there is a key role for the scottish
parliament as with all parliaments
to help create a better healthier future
for us all
and to engage with the people they
represent
especially our young people
presiding officer
first minister members of the scottish
parliament
the duke of nazis of rothsay and i will
continue to follow your progress with
the closest of interest
and we extend you all
our warmest good wishes as you embark on
this sixth session of parliament
[Applause]
thank you your majesty nicholas sturgeon
msp who i now invite to address the
chamber
your majesty
your royal highnesses presiding officer
fellow members of parliament and
distinguished guests
your majesty we are deeply grateful for
your presence here with us today
but our pleasure of course is tinged
with regret at an absence
this is the first time you have opened
our parliament without the duke of
edinburgh by your side on behalf of
everyone in our chamber and across
scotland i convey again our deep
sympathy and shared sorrow at your loss
your majesty thank you for honoring us
by opening this sixth session of our
parliament and for your kind and
thoughtful address to us today
you have been a steadfast friend of our
parliament since its establishment in
1999 and i know how much all msps down
the years and across all parties value
the support and the wise counsel that
you offer us
your address is the highlight of a day
which is both a ceremony and a
celebration it is a democratic and a
cultural moment
the wonderful music traditional and
modern that we have just listened to
underlines that
and the last song we heard from
musicians in exile
reminds us just how deeply our culture
is enriched by the contribution of new
scots from around the world
we are a nation that welcomes people
from wherever they come
a nation proud to call itself simply
home for everyone who chooses to live
here
and it is indeed fitting that the
growing diversity of modern scotland is
now reflected more clearly in this new
parliament
we now have amongst our members more
women than ever before
more people from ethnic minorities than
ever before and more people living with
visible disabilities than ever before
when members were sworn in they took
oaths in gaelic german urdu bsl and many
other languages and dialects besides
now all parties still have more to do
of that there is no doubt
but may's election marked an important
milestone in ensuring that this
parliament an institution which exists
above all to serve the public and give
expression to the priorities and
aspirations of our nation now looks and
sounds much more like the people we
represent
that really matters especially at this
moment of change and transition as our
world